Welcome to "Ear Biscuits", I'm Rhett.
And I'm Link.
This week at the
roundtable of dim lighting,
I'm gonna tell you a story.
I wanna take you--
Story time.
A true story, I wanna
take you on a journey.
A chain of events that began
in the wake of episode before last,
Our First Memories episode.
Yep.
You remember that, Rhett?
I've already forgotten it.
Well, you know the story I'm gonna tell.
It's a story of confrontation, of pain,
forgiveness and the power of words.
You really set it up.
And it's also the story,
specifically, of one word.
One very special word.
It's been a wild ride over
the last couple of weeks
and I just got to a
point where I was like,
"I have to share what has happened."
Maybe this won't be as sensational
or as groundbreaking to
anybody else but for me--
You talking about it in that tone,
I think it will be
sensational just because--
I'm sensationalizing it but it--
I don't know if it requires that.
Yeah, I don't think it requires that.
I will say that it's just been something
that's been deeply meaningful to me
and I think it's shaped
who I am as a person.
It's directly related to this podcast.
Wow.
And--
Does it have to be that deep
in order for it to be
worthy of the podcast?
Okay, that's fair.
Well, it has shaped how I conduct myself
on this podcast moving forward.
It's a wild ride, I'm--
Well, I'm looking forward to that, Link.
But it has an unexpected
double happy ending.
By show of hands, who's ready
for a double happy ending?
I don't know if I can handle that.
You shouldn't have
actually raised your hands
because that's kinda
weird, kind of awkward.
Before we get into Link's story--
Do you want a double happy ending today?
Nope, I don't believe in happy endings.
I don't go to those kinds of places.
You talking about like fairy tales?
The first thing I wanna
do is I wanna let you know
that the Mythical Kitchen
has launched its own podcast
called "A Hot Dog Is a Sandwich"
and it is a weekly podcast
that comes out every Wednesday.
I'm so excited for 'em.
Where Josh and Nicole will debate
a controversial food topic.
Now, one of the things that
we noticed about Josh early on
when he started working here was,
I mean, you've seen him demonstrate this
on Good Mythical Morning
and the Mythical Kitchen.
Dude is a food encyclopedia
but he's not just an encyclopedia
because an encyclopedia
presents just facts.
No, Josh goes above facts
and starts inserting his own
very well-formed, well-reasoned
opinions about food,
which is a subjective thing to begin with.
I mean we're having like a party.
Like a Mythical Entertainment party.
People gather around it.
I see that there was like a
crowd of people over there
and they were all around
Josh just grilling him
about food questions
and so I went over there
and just got a kick out of
just listening in on it.
The podcast wasn't our
idea but I'm very excited
that now, you have the opportunity
to have the same experience that we have
at our Mythical get-togethers.
And then--
Did I say what the first episode was?
No, Nicole is there to--
Balance him.
I don't know exactly what she,
I hope balance him.
Keep him in check.
First episode, they're arguing
about whether or not
pineapple belongs on pizza,
which is a controversial thing.
It's already out wherever you listen to,
if you're listening to this,
you can also listen to that.
And then a portion of the podcast
and video form will come out the day after
on the Mythical Kitchen YouTube
channel, so check it out.
Check it out, y'all.
Check that out.
I have a little something that
happened to me this morning
that I think I need to just get out there.
Sensationalize it.
Like, did it change your life?
I don't think
it need to be sensationalized.
Is it a story of pain,
forgiveness and the power of words?
No, it's just a fun little story, Link.
All right, okay.
The bar can be low.
First of all, my wife
is out of town, okay?
She's hanging out with friends.
Explains why you're dressed
like a children's entertainer.
Right, exactly.
Well, first of all, my
wife doesn't dress me
when she's there.
Yes, she does.
She doesn't lay my clothes out anymore.
It is funny, because this morning,
Christy happened to be
standing in the closet
when I was also in the
closet picking out my clothes
and I was like, "Christy,
I want you to pick out
"what I'm gonna wear today."
That's weird, that's weird.
Did she?
And this is it?
No, once I got here,
Kiko said they wanted me
to wear merch so I had to change clothes.
Oh, okay.
This is not
what Christy picked.
What about the outerwear?
I changed the jacket
'cause it didn't match.
What about the jeans?
You had a story to tell.
So she's out of town so,
the McLaughlin household
is hanging on by thread.
The kids, I think they're being fed.
I'm pretty sure, I have
seen some like crumbs
in the kitchen.
I doubt that they're bathing
but that's not my responsibility.
So, of course--
My wife bathed me.
I have to take them to school.
And not every day.
I don't have to pick them up every day
but I have to take them
to school every day
while she's gone.
And first of all, just
shout out to the parents
who have to take their kids to school
and pick them up and take them everywhere.
I think you should unionize
because just after doing this
just for a couple of days,
which I'm not saying I've
never taken my kids to school
but like, when my wife is not there
and so I've got to kind of be responsible
for getting them up and
making sure they're ready
and everybody getting
ready to go out the door
and then also take them.
And then, what my wife has to do
is she's got to pick them
up but then also take them
to all the other crap that they got to do
and I just really feel like
there should be a union.
I mean if the taxi drivers can unionize,
why can't the parental drivers unionize?
Because they got rights.
They have to have some rights like--
Like what?
Like the right to play the
music that they wanna play,
not that the kids wanna play.
Oh.
The right to keep the kids
from eating crumby foods
in the back of the car.
The right to keep the kids from leaving
their freaking belongings in the car.
Okay.
Those kinds of things.
I think it's also the right to insist
that the kids respond when
the parent asks a question.
How was your day?
Yeah, you're actually gonna
give a thoughtful response.
Why are we talking like this?
And it can lead to a conversation.
Parents unite!
But this morning was
more difficult than usual
because as you know, I
recently got solar panels
put on the top of my house so
that I can go totally solar,
go off the grid, disconnect,
which is technically
illegal, I've learned.
You can't disconnect from the
grid so I'm still on the grid
but now, I'm giving power
back to the power company.
I don't know, solar panels are weird
but I'm glad we have them
but today was the day
that they were gonna be turned on
after they pass inspection.
Sounds like a big moment
where nothing perceptible happens.
Right, especially when it's cloudy.
But my wife calls me last
night and says, "Oh."
You can call her Jessie.
She has a name.
No, I can't, she said I couldn't.
Okay.
Just kidding.
Jessie called me and said,
"Oh, they're gonna cut the
solar panels on tomorrow
"and the inspectors gonna be there
"and the guy from the
solar company told me
"that occasionally, the inspector will ask
"to go inside the house to
inspect your smoke detectors."
Okay.
I was like, okay, well.
I went on the Internet.
I looked up like California regulations
about smoke detectors.
I assumed just based on what I've learned
about living in California
that they require like a
smoke detector in every room,
a smoke detector tied around
the neck of every person,
two smoke detectors on your pets,
one smoke detector on the
aquarium for your fish
and seven smoke detectors
on top of your house.
And every smoke detector--
There's a lot of regulations.
Needs to have a sticker that says--
This can cause cancer.
This smoke detector contains materials,
which are known to the state of California
to contain carcinogens.
So not only it detects smoke--
By the way.
But kill you.
Everything in California
has this sticker on it.
You walk into a building
there's like a plaque.
You open the door to your car,
there's a sticker on your car that says,
anywhere you look, this so-and-so
has materials known to
the state of California
to cause cancer.
Yeah, so anyway, I was like,
"Well, I don't know if we
got enough smoke detectors.
"We got one in all the bedrooms
"but like since we like redid the kitchen,
"I think we got rid of some downstairs."
So,
I installed,
first of all, smoke
detector's technology--
Oh, gosh, yes.
It's updated since last
time I looked into it.
No longer, they don't come with a battery.
Or they come with a
special kind of battery
that never requires you
to change it for years
and you don't have to put
regular batteries in there.
You just take the thing
out and activate it.
Like press a button, flip a little switch
and then it's good to go.
So, of course, we had dinner
last night with a friend
so we were out late and so I
didn't install it last night.
I was like, "I'll do it in the morning
"before I take the kids to school,"
and then I kinda got up
late, they kinda got up late
and we're like struggling
to get out the door
and then I'm like, "Guys, sorry,
"I got to install the
smoke detector right now."
And so I'm like going
downstairs and getting the drill
so I could like drill 'cause
you got to do the little
drywall screws and that kind of thing.
And I'm like, "You're both gonna be
"a little bit late for school."
That's the first thing I said.
I was just setting expectations.
It's like, Dad has already failed.
Yeah.
But we got to have a smoke detector
so I do the smoke detector,
did a pretty good job,
put it up there and activated it.
We're already a little bit late
and then while I'm doing it,
I'm being very dad-ish.
I'm saying things like, "Is there anything
"that you guys could be doing?"
Yeah.
I was like, "Locke,
check the freaking trash.
"How's the trash?
"Does the trash need to be taken out?"
And he goes and he's like, "No."
So then I had to throw away
the smoke detector packaging
and I go to the trash.
The trash in the kitchen
is completely full.
And I'm like, "You lied to me!"
Oh.
I was like, "You said it was fine."
He was like, "It is fine."
I was like, "Are we seeing
the same trash can right now?"
I was like, "Take it out!"
I think he meant it wasn't overflowing.
It basically was.
It was within an inch of the top.
I don't know what he
thinks is when it's ready.
So next thing I know,
so I see Locke put the trash can,
trash bag over his
shoulder like a knapsack.
Santa.
Walked out the door
and then he comes back
upstairs and he's like,
'cause you have to
kinda go down the stairs
in our front house to get down there.
Again, we're now we're
like 12 minutes late.
He says, "Trash bag broke."
What is he, a caveman?
I go outside and I see--
That's all he said.
At the bottom of the stairs, right?
When you get at the bottom of the stairs
and hit the driveway.
It looks like one of
those commercials where,
like a Geico commercial
with the raccoons like,
"All right, we need some
really realistic looking trash,
"like lots of eggs, lots of bananas,
"throw some blueberries in there,
"maybe some old coffee grounds."
Like--
Everywhere.
Classic trash, wet--
Did he keep walking with it or something?
It seemed like it because
there was a little piece
of a carrot and a little
piece of a pea on the steps
so something was leaking.
There was a hole, some things got out
and then the whole thing came apart.
And all he did was come up
and say, "Trash bag broke."
And, of course, I'm
already upset with myself
and I'm doing the thing that you do
when you're upset with yourself
and you take it out on your
children, if you're a good dad,
and I was like, "What did you do wrong?
"Like, were you swinging it?
"Did it hit the?"
And the Shepherd was like,
"Well ,he probably dragged it."
Like, Shepherd's giving his commentary.
Shepherd was like, "That's
why there's a pea on the steps
"'cause he was dragging it."
He's forensic.
And so then, I'm like, well--
Investigating.
You guys settle in because
we got to clean this up.
So now, we go down there and
I'm like getting paper towels
and picking this crap
up and then sweeping it
and then we have to hose
the whole thing down.
He also got onto the car.
I'm hosing the car down.
And, of course, no one is saying anything.
Like once we start cleaning,
there's just no conversation.
Oh.
It's just this is our lives.
So they were 30 minutes late
for school today and we bonded.
Wow, it's really all your fault.
The whole trashcan thing was your idea.
It was.
All those blueberries
and bananas and et cetera
could all just be, banana peels,
could just be sitting
in the trash right now.
I'm glad you made it.
I did, I'm okay.
Thanks for worrying about me.
Let's plug mythical.com.
I changed into this shirt
even though my wife told me
to wear something else.
It's something wash is what they call it.
They call that a, what do they call that?
Crystal wash.
Wash by a girl named Crystal.
Yeah.
And then sent out to you.
Each one is one of a kind, mythical.com.
We got joggers, hoodies, t-shirts.
Crystal worked at the Belk, remember that?
Up at Cary Towne Center.
Yeah, she give you a
discount on some parfum.
I thought that I wanted to date her.
Well, she smelled like
every perfume combined.
Oh, gosh.
'Cause she worked in
that part of the store.
Instant headache for me, man.
Just can't.
Yeah, it's too much for me too.
Mythical.com.
Rep your boys.
All right, can we get into this?
Let's see, where do I wanna start?
I wanna start this story with
a word that never existed.
That's what I'm calling
the part one of this story.
Now, my family, particularly,
my mom's side of the family,
my nanny, her mama, had like
nine brothers and sisters
and they have this own strange
strain of Southern vocabulary
and over the years, sometimes,
I'll say some words,
you be like, "What was that?"
Or we'll get on conversations
about weird Southern slang
and I'll always end up remembering words
that my nanny or
particularly, my Aunt Vicky.
Nanny's the oldest of the siblings
and then Aunt Vicky is one
of the youngest siblings
if not the youngest, I don't think.
And they've lived together
their whole lives.
For a long time.
Nanny never drove, Vicky
would drive them to work
at the shirt factory
where they were inspected
and folded shirts for like decades.
That was Erwin, right?
No, in Lillington.
Across--
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Where that Burger King is
on the far side of town.
Yep.
So, they spent so much time together
that they perpetuate these words
that became very specific
to like that family.
I'll give you just a couple of examples.
Now, both of these are related to poop.
Because it seems like they
made a very strong connection
between your poop and your health
and, of course, there's people
who write books about this.
I think they were on to something.
They were coming around, yeah.
Gut health.
But they wouldn't call it
poop, they wouldn't say shit.
They wouldn't say that.
They referred to poop as
hockey and they would say,
they would ask me when I
would go over there as a kid,
they're saying, "Do you
need to take a hockey?"
Is it that's so weird?
And I thought that it was--
Yes.
A really bad word.
I was like, "Whoa, that
is like a expletive,
"I would never say that."
But did you make a
connection to the sport?
I knew what they were talking about.
No, no, no, but--
And I knew it was also the
word for a sport but I--
Do you find--
I did not and I still
cannot make a correlation
between something related
to the sport of hockey
and the sport of taking a crap.
Well, the first thing
that comes to mind for me is the puck.
I guess if you--
Every once in a while,
you make one that's shaped like a puck.
Depending on what you ate.
I've never pooped a puck.
You've pooped puck-like things, probably.
I've pooped--
You pooped puck-like poops.
Really dark poops before--
How many puck-like poops can you poop?
But never puck-colored
poop, never that dark.
Oh, have you ever taken Pepto?
'Cause Pepto makes it black.
Yeah, but it doesn't
make it hard like a puck.
No, that's good point.
They would always ask me.
And especially if I like,
if I wasn't doing good or I wasn't hungry
or something like that, why
do you need take a hockey?
And then they would say,
"You need to do a bad job?
"You need to do a bad job?"
Hold on, this is also a poop?
Yes.
Dude, this is why,
this is one of the reasons
that your anal retentive.
I know.
Is because they told you
that pooping was a bad job.
And first of all, they told
you that it was a sport
that in the South, no one likes.
Right.
Before the hurricanes came in--
Isn't it so weird?
We hated hockey and so,
it's like we didn't like,
it's the least favorite
sport and a bad job.
So, your relationship with poop,
it was unhealthy from the start.
It's all your family's fault.
I would go out in the backyard,
and I would like climb trees
and hang out in the backyard
and then if I felt like I needed to--
Take a bad job?
Do number two, I would just
kinda squat down and hold it
and squeeze it in.
Yeah, because it was a bad job.
And I don't know if they
knew that I would do that
so then they were like really harped on me
about, have you taken a hockey today?
Do you need to hockey?
They put a lot of pressure on you.
I don't remember thinking
putting any effort--
I know.
Into thinking about my poops
until I became like an adult man.
I mean this is all a tangential,
yet very insightful rabbit trail here.
My point at the moment
is just that they would
use weird terminology.
And there was another word
that did not have anything to do with poop
that they would they would use
a lot and the word was quare.
Now I'm not talking about the word queer,
even though if you, like,
especially not to let the queer in like,
in modern parlance of our times.
Right.
The Q in LGBTQ+.
I'm definitely not talking about that.
You're talking about the
traditional use of the word queer
which would be unusual.
Unusual.
Right.
But quare is kinda like
a sister word to that,
which they would use all the time.
It was a specialized descriptor
for someone who was peculiar
in a specifically picky
or opinionated way.
Matter of fact, if I would express concern
or disdain for something that they liked,
like let's say tomatoes.
They be like, "Oh, don't be so quare."
And so it could mean picky
but like very specifically
peculiarly picky.
So not like in tomatoes
isn't the best example
but they would call me quare a lot.
And so you knew--
And I've told this.
You told me about it and so
my perspective on this word--
You never heard of it.
Well, I'll say that my
perspective on a lot of the words
that your family used,
because it's interesting,
because my family is very Southern
but they come from South Georgia
and then we moved
eventually to North Carolina
when I was a kid but my parents
are like from the South,
grew up in the South.
You've seen my mom when she
was a guest on GMM trying to,
when we did a lie detector thing.
Yeah, very Southern.
She's a Southern woman but
first of all, she didn't have,
like, she talked like a Southern woman
and had a lot of vocabulary
that was kinda typical
to just people in the South
but it was nothing as specific
as some of the words that you use.
So my theory about a lot of these words
was that they seemed very,
very specifically regional
and then in some cases,
my theory was specific
to your family, right?
Yeah.
But the word quare,
I thought that you thought,
I thought that you were
like misremembering
and that they were just--
That was your stance.
They're just saying queer.
They were just using
the word queer because--
Or that they meant queer
but they said it wrong.
Maybe.
Yeah, because you could
substitute queer for quare
and it wouldn't be like,
if it would still kinda make sense
but it's not as specific.
It will still work enough.
Yeah, but because you've never heard of it
and we had this conversation
before and it was,
or multiple times but
it was basically like,
yeah, you have to be mistaken.
We talked to Stevie about this,
she was getting a kick out of it
but she had never heard of it either.
She from North Carolina.
In fact, no one that I could
talk to outside of my family
had heard of this word,
so I started to think
maybe it is something my family,
in fact, not even Google--
You can't find it on the Internet.
Had heard of quare.
So I'm trying to convince,
I remember this conversation
with you and Stevie,
I'm like, it is an intentional expression
of something more specific than
queer in the old definition.
And then when I couldn't
find it on Google,
I had to resign to never being believed
and you know what, Rhett,
it hurt, it hurt me, man.
It's a weight that I carried.
Okay, that's a little quare of you.
I'll come back to all this
but look at that is like a precursor.
like in "Fellowship of the Ring"
where it's like Cate Blanchett
gives the whole backstory
of the ring, okay?
And you know that ring is gonna come back.
Just as dramatic.
And then in the next scene,
it's a wonderful day in the Shire.
So let's skip over to the Shire.
Mm, I really like to play that soundtrack
but that wouldn't work.
I'm going about my
happy business last week
doing some work.
I call my work happy business.
I don't know if you ever noticed that.
As opposed to bad job?
What are you up today?
You need to do a bad job?
I can't do a bad job at my happy business.
No, it's not bad job, it's a bad job.
It's like--
Bad job, it's like one-word.
Very specifically a poop.
Greg, I don't think Greg who works here
is constantly checking
our Facebook messages
but apparently, one
came across, bless you,
one came across his desktop--
Thank you.
And he forwarded the email to me
and a lot of the people in this room
who have stuff to do with "Ear Biscuits".
It was an emotional Facebook message
in response to our first memories podcast.
And it was written by, and
this is a long message.
I feel like you kinda,
just in case you missed it.
I'll get some recap.
It was written by the
granddaughter of my babysitter.
Her name isn't Betty but I will call
this granddaughter of my babysitter Betty
just to help tell the story, okay?
And I did get her permission to relay
this story to you guys today.
So I just wanna say all of that up front,
I'm changing her name to Betty
and she said we could
have this conversation
that I could read excerpts
from our correspondence.
Now, yeah, as you were saying,
I should recap what we said
on that First Memories podcast.
Now, this wasn't my first memory
but once I started talk about memories,
I started talking about my babysitter
when I was in grade school
and how she rolled my arm
up in her car window one day
and how she teased me about
my mom not picking me up.
There she don't come
and I said that I had separation anxiety
that I didn't tell anybody at the time.
And she encouraged you to remove
or try to remove the wart
that was on her finger.
Yeah.
And I think I proceeded
to call her a witch.
Well--
But again, I was joking, I
don't think she was a witch
but you basically--
I used her real name.
You used her real name.
And I'm not gonna use it right now.
I also use the term demented
in the course of our conversation
and then we moved on.
Not only with the podcast but
with the rest of our lives
until I get this message.
And I'm gonna read a big
chunk of this message.
Some of it, I've taken out
just to kinda keep it moving
but there's still a lot
here but I'm gonna read it.
Here it goes.
My grandmother was, and
I have removed her name.
Well, just say Betty.
Well, no, the granddaughter's
name is Betty.
Oh, got it.
Okay?
Betty wrote, "My grandmother was blank.
"Please accept my deepest
apologies if for any reason,
"you really think she was doing something
"that appeared to be demented.
"I truly do not think she was
deliberately trying to harm,
"torture, hurt, make
you feel uncomfortable.
"I am sure she did not want
to cause you any trauma.
"I don't think my grandmother
"would deliberately do
anything to harm a child.
"Now, she very well would have
said, there she don't come
"but I think it was
her way of passing time
"and was teasing you but
had she or I had realized
"it caused you any pain,
it would have stopped.
"It actually breaks my heart
"because she loved her Linkadink.
"She loved all her kids in her care.
"I hope that I can resolve this in my mind
"as what a young child sees
"versus what is or did take place.
"I'm hoping to that whatever
the reality is or was,
"it is being overblown and
not being taken seriously.
"She told all the kids
to keep their hands away
"from the windows and doors
of the Chevrolet Monte Carlo
"and it was not a
Cadillac, as you remember.
"The particular car had
some of the fastest buttons
"once she touched them.
I do remember that.
It did come up fast.
Fast windows in that Monte Carlo.
"She cried about the fact
"your little hand got caught in the window
"and I remember her pretty nice on it.
"I am sorry you remember it as thinking
"she meant to do it on purpose
and not as an accident."
Because in your story,
she did it and then she did it again.
Just to recap.
"Remembering it being a Cadillac
"instead of what it actually
was, a Chevrolet Monte Carlo,
"can be seen as an example of
reality versus what we think.
"Please don't get me wrong,
"I'm not going to justify
it if you really think
"she did hurt your on purpose.
"If she did, I will
say that was sickening.
"I just hope it is a
difference in memories.
"Again, I apologize.
"I'm sorry for any trauma, real or not,
"that you went through.
"This has really bothered me to the point
"I am crying hysterically and
I feel as if it is something
"I have to personally do something about.
"I just don't know how to
wrap my head around it.
"I have never heard of or have known
"of any complaints against her
"and this is so shocking to me.
"This has stunned me to my core."
Wow.
I read this email and like,
even rereading it, I'm
having the same feelings,
like I just like,
I felt horrible.
In first, I was like wow,
I never really thought
that like her granddaughter
would be listening.
Yeah.
That's not the audience
I was thinking about
when I shared this story.
Well, not only that,
I think the message came like
the day the podcast came out
so it was someone who--
It was pretty quick.
Who listens regularly.
Well, I mean, there was a Facebook clip
and you know, Facebook
clips can really get around.
There was a Facebook clip
about this story, right?
Kiko looks like, "Mm,
yeah, it's my fault."
No, it's not your fault.
It's Link's fault.
I actually suggest, I
was like, hey, this is,
maybe we should start putting clips
of "Ear Biscuits" on YouTube
and maybe this is a better candidate
because it was like it's
such a memorable story.
Right.
And that's how I thought about it.
Like an engaging story from my past
that was like kinda wild.
Yeah.
And it gave window on
how I thought as a kid
but like I just didn't think about
like my babysitter's family listening.
So I was pretty shook up
but this isn't about
me, this is about Betty.
And I mean, I'll be honest,
my first thought was this
is just a Facebook message.
I can just ignore it.
This will go away.
I definitely don't have to say anything
and then I reread it and I'm like,
oh, my gosh, she's crying hysterically,
she feels horrible,
she's like questioning.
Like, I gotta say something.
So I wrote back.
I won't read all of it but I said,
Betty, well, her name's not
Betty, I didn't address her as,
I addressed her with a real
name but I'm not doing that now.
Which is?
That was a test.
Betty, I'm sorry that
my story has upset you
and called into question your
memories of your grandmother.
That was not my intention.
And then I go on to share that
I can believe to her point
that she didn't mean any ill intent.
I told her I told the story
from the perspective of
the young child that I was
and I hold no ill will
towards her now as an adult.
Of course, she's passed away,
so I hold no ill will
towards her memory or--
And may I just interject
as someone who is the kind of person
who enjoys what in the South
we call messing with people?
Yeah, yeah.
And I also, I like messing with kids.
The whole there she don't
come thing, I would do that.
Yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
Now, if I didn't found out
that oh, he actually has
separation anxiety or whatever,
then I would be like, oh.
But I'm just saying that like,
even as you told the story
in your childhood version,
even though I said she
was a witch doing that.
But that was more about the
work part, like, you know.
Yeah, yeah.
Even then--
Witches have warts and you were making
some sort of like connection.
I wasn't thinking anything
negative about her.
I was just like this is just
a woman with a sense of humor
and like you're remembering it in a way
from the child's perspective, so
but I know that some people--
I didn't think that she--
Took it differently than that.
Yeah, I didn't think that
she did that on purpose
to like hurt me as deeply as it did
and there's no way she
could have known that
because I didn't tell anybody that.
Again, it was inside, that
was an internal dialogue that,
but then the part about the window,
I do think my memory was
that I think she did that on purpose.
Right.
She's not rolling it down.
But maybe it was when she panicked
and was trying to roll it down
and she rolled it up more.
Or maybe you did have an experience
with getting your hand
caught in a Cadillac window--
And then she had nothing
to do with it.
And you conflated
the two memories.
It wasn't a Monte Carlo.
I went on to say as we
have discussed many times
on our show and in that
particular episode as well,
memories are not always
reliable and accurate.
And then I said, I hope this
can put your mind at ease.
Because I hated knowing
that she was so upset
and then I said we are
currently reediting the show
to censor all references to her name.
It may take a few days for
that update to take effect
in the system but rest
assured, we've made the edits.
Thank you for reaching out.
Again, I'm sorry to have caused you pain.
Because I really was.
I mean it was like you
could tell the emotion
in the way that she wrote her message.
It was like, just kinda like--
She was shaken to the core.
It was something that
she wrote it in a way
that she would say it to you, you know?
It was very like stream of consciousness.
Oh, man, but that was
kinda tough but I was like,
and when I wrote the email to the,
I was like, "Greg give her this message."
I also said like, "And I
have learned my lesson.
"I'm not gonna use real names
in incriminating stories."
Well, okay, and you're gonna get into
the rest of the story in a second
but I was, because she was so,
because you read this to me,
she was so shaken up that we actually,
I started looking the
legality around defamation.
Oh, you did?
Yeah, and started finding
out whether or not
you could be sued for defaming--
Based on Jacob's body language right now,
I think he was doing the
same thing on his office.
No, no, but you cannot,
you can't defame a dead person
because what's at stake in defamation
is someone's reputation and a dead person
doesn't have a reputation.
So just from a legal standpoint--
They don't?
You can say whatever you
want to about a dead person.
Dead people have a reputation.
That's pretty much all they've got.
Oh, well--
Memories.
That is the ironic thing
as I was reading about it
'cause I was like, yeah, you
think about someone's legacy.
So you can ruin someone's legacy
but they don't have a living reputation.
Just look on the Internet.
But the interesting
thing about it is that,
because I really got into this,
and this is maybe, I
don't wanna be a lawyer
but sometimes, I start looking into this
and I realized maybe
this is what my dad was
because I get interested in this.
If someone, like okay,
well, what about an estate?
Like can you talk crap about
Elvis and then his estate?
You kinda--
Right, right.
No, but what can happen is if
there's a defamation lawsuit
that a person has started before
they die and then they die,
their estate can continue
the defamation lawsuit
but they cannot start
one that did not exist
when they were alive.
So, you were technically on the clear.
So if you wanna be on the up and up
and talk shit about somebody,
wait until they die.
I think that's the--
And that's why tell-all
biographies come out
right when somebody dies.
When somebody dies.
So you've got these people--
Oh, you think they've sat,
they've written it and
they're sitting on it, yes.
100%, people are sitting
on all these scandalous stories
and then somebody dies
and you got two things.
A, they're in the news
so you can jump on that.
This seems icky-bad.
But B,
gold on, I've got all kinds
of things written about you.
I've got my whole tell-all about Link.
Expose?
Yeah, and I don't know
what I'm gonna call it yet
but maybe Linkadink.
Linkadink it and sink it.
Linkadink it and sink it,
and I'm so ready to release
it if I outlive you.
Just know that that's coming.
Your reputation will be in tatters.
Well, you know what, when you die first,
I'm gonna dig it up,
I'm gonna change my name to
your name and release it.
So everything you write about
me will actually be about you.
I don't know if that'll be believable
based on the content but--
Just because we're different heights.
Okay, oh, you're gonna change all the,
I listed your height so many times.
So, I didn't feel, I felt like
it was against the momentum of,
I don't know, my initial
reaction is like write the email
and I don't know if you'd
call it an apology but,
well, I was sorry that
my story had hurt her
and called in to question how
she viewed her grandmother.
I did apologize for that
and I was sorry for that.
But it's not like you're
apologizing to somebody's face
and you know how they
respond and you feel,
you can either feel relief or
like can clarify or whatever
and this is all on Facebook,
not Messenger but the
Facebook email thingy.
But thank goodness, she did respond.
And respond she'd,
thank goodness on so many
levels that she responded.
Can I just read her response to you?
Yes.
Because I didn't know, I didn't know how,
I couldn't have predicted
how she would respond.
It's like well, that's not,
now, I'm just angry and,
are you saying that you
didn't mean any of it
and why did you say it?
I don't know, I was
like, I was apprehensive.
Here's her response.
"Thank you so very much for your response.
"I'm so very relieved to have
an understanding about this.
"Thank you for reaching out to me
"so that I can now see
"how we both could have been seeing this
"as just a difference of memories
"and the way we look at things.
"I accept your apology wholeheartedly
"and thank you for what you are doing.
"It feels good to be,
"to clear something up, man,
"to be to be forgiven for something.
"Being from the creek and growing up there
"as well as having
family and friends there,
"it was concerning that
her name was out there
"and associated with being demented.
"I think that was the biggest
issue for me and my family."
And then it goes further.
Get ready.
She goes on to say,
"Again, I will say she,
as well as most of us,
"has or have some peculiar or quare
"or different ways of thinking and doing
"but to now know she didn't
intentionally harm you
"brings me comfort."
And there you have it.
The big old B story to this.
Here's the sentence right here.
And she put it on quotes.
Again, I will say she,
as well as most of us,
has or have some peculiar or,
in quotes, Q-U-A-R-E, end quote,
or different, peculiar, quare,
or different way of thinking.
That's how you spell it.
And doing.
She used the word in a sentence.
She in the same sentence.
Defined the word.
She spelled the word with an A in it.
You were really holding on to this.
She put it in quotes!
Undeniable!
It exists!
Quare exists!
We'll come back to that.
She is not done.
She continues, "I've been late
"to the Rhett and Link GMM party
"but I've enjoyed watching and listening
"to the, quote, hometown boys,
"that have made it as you have!"
Exclamation point.
Hmm.
Like, whoa, what's happening here?
"In fact, I asked and
received from my sister
"a copy of 'The Lost Causes
of Bleak Creek' for Christmas.
"I had just started the book on Sunday
"and then I saw your
post about my grandmother
"and then I was disillusioned."
Then stopped reading.
What?
Immediately.
And then she said--
Burned the book.
She said, "I will keep reading now
"as well as keeping watching and cheering
"for that sweet cute little feller
"that we called Linkadink."
She was a fan, she had the book.
I will the book out of
the toilet, let it air dry
and continue reading it.
Did you hockey the book?
Did you hockey the novel?
Linkadink.
Did you do a bad job in that novel?
Oh, man.
"Thank you again and
I very much appreciate
"your answering my message and especially
"that you would be willing
to remove her name."
Oh, man, I have never been so relieved
to have an apology accepted and trust me,
I've apologized a lot in my life.
Probably still not as
much as I should have
but to feel that amount of relief
and by the way, I'm not
done with her message.
But at this point in the message,
to fill that amount of relief,
I was so glad that I did respond
but then, also, to feel
the elation and validation
that this word was not just in my family's
twisted microcosm of vocabulary
and extended to at least
other people in the county.
It extended out a little bit.
I find it interesting that
you feel so vindicated
when I don't really
think much has changed.
It's still something that some people say.
You didn't believe me, man.
You didn't believe me.
Well, we'll wait till we get to the end.
I still have a theory about this word
but I don't wanna upset you at this point.
All right, so then she keeps writing.
"I'm also thankful for you and Rhett
"sharing your lost years
and how you have evolved,"
oh, my gosh, she's been
listening to the podcast.
"It is very interesting to me
"to see your transition from religion.
"I have questioned
Christianity, the Bible,
"the facts and other things myself.
"I think many have.
"I'm impressed by your
candor and knowledge.
"I have relatives and
friends who are LGBTQ
"and have always been
leery of religious bigots
"and the cherry-picking that some used
"to keep their bigotry going
and or using it as an excuse
"to not be a good person.
All of a sudden, she's
going out in this message.
Oh, wow.
"Living and growing up in
the Bible Belt is challenging
"and with the political BS
with the wannabe dictator,
"it's challenging on a daily basis now."
She's getting political.
Dang, you wouldn't think
that the Venn diagram
of people who use the word quare
and people who would say the
things that she's saying,
there doesn't seem like,
there may be just one person if that--
I am not reading her--
That crossover.
Her tirade about,
her hot take on our lost years
and I'm not reading this
to be self-aggrandizing,
I'm reading it to make that point, Rhett,
that people who use quare
are thoughtful people.
Now, whether you disagree
with her point of view,
that's not the point I'm making right now.
But she's got a strong one.
She's got a strong point of view
and it is thoughtful
and there's heart in it.
Living and growing, yeah, okay.
So, "I can't believe how some
of the most educated people
"are truly shameful and
can't get their past,
"can't get past their
own biases and beliefs.
"Looking forward to
more from you and Rhett.
"Thanks again and please know
"that there is and are no
hard feelings on my part."
That feels good.
Very next sentence, "We had snow here."
And now, she's going into the weather.
Oh, I love that!
This message is a journey
unlike any Facebook message
anyone has ever received.
She wasn't just talking
about the weather though.
"We had snow here and most all
are a little giddy about it
"but your response to me tops that."
It is better than snow.
Better than snow.
'Cause it it snows like
once every three years
in North Carolina.
Yeah, man,
snow's a big deal.
And like this is February
and like is a big deal
but she said that my response made her,
it topped that, made her giddy.
And then she says, "It has
made me a better person
"and giving me peace to
know that you took the time
"to read my message and
in kind, to respond.
"You didn't have to and
that's what makes you a great
"and decent person."
I'm gonna cry.
And then she says, "Go
rock on now because I am."
Wow, this woman is amazing.
Her name's not Betty.
Got rock on now 'cause I am.
Your name's not Betty, you are amazing
and you have made me a better person.
What are you doing saying that
I made you a better person?
I did something,
I didn't take your feelings into account
and I put this thing out
there on the Internet
just because I,
it seemed confessional but honestly,
it was mostly just for kicks
and I think as I told the story,
I was like oh, it had an impact on me.
A lot of times on this podcast,
I say something just to get it out there
and I don't even know
what I mean to myself
but I that it was--
That explains quite a lot.
It does, doesn't it?
Yet, she's saying that like,
this made her a better person?
Like, I'm floored by that.
I mean the shoe, to me is on
the other foot big time and--
Again, having an enriching
interaction with somebody,
especially one in which
there was a misunderstanding
or conflict and to see that
resolved, I can see her point.
But yeah, it's more that
she what's the better person
but you extended an olive branch.
And she graciously accepted it,
'cause it's like even when you apologize,
you feel like this is
gonna be picked apart.
And I don't wanna get on a
soapbox here but like there's--
That's what happens in public.
I'll inch on to the soapbox
that like if somebody
sincerely apologizes,
it's like, I know what
it feels like to be sorry
and then not know exactly the
right words to say, you know?
And it feels good when you sincerely
empathize with pain you've caused
and you're sorry for it
and then somebody has a,
they have a gracious response
because I think because
of the culture we're in,
I had a heightened anxiety.
And at first, that was part
of my knee-jerk response
to say hi, you know what, we
can set the Facebook thing
so she can't even see that we read this
so there's culpability that like okay,
she doesn't even have
to know that we saw it
or that I saw it.
And so, a reasonable conclusion
could be that we didn't see it,
not that I actively didn't respond
because responding opens you up
to a whole new level of criticism.
And to be clear,
we don't respond to every
complaint and every concern
because we get a lot of
them on a regular basis
for all kinds of things that
people have been offended by.
Yep, that's true.
And sometimes, it feels like,
but this felt different
for reasons that you've already kinda--
It was it was very deeply
personal and I just couldn't,
I'm not tooting my own horn,
I'm saying that like, I thought
about not saying anything.
Yeah, I could and so I went
forward and then it was,
but to me, it's like okay,
what have I learned in this process?
Well, before you move on 'cause I--
I think it's my last question but--
I think you're making a really good point
about the apology thing because,
man, I've seen it so many
times in the past few years.
Somebody does something
that's legitimately upsetting to people.
And a lot of times,
it might be something
that was unintentional
or just sort of misguided
and then they apologize,
they make an apology video on YouTube,
they do the apology tweet where
you just take your notes app
and you write something and
you put it on your Twitter,
this is just a part of
culture at this point.
People who have any sort of following
or are public figures in any way,
at times, will probably have to apologize
and it is a guarantee
that a certain percentage of the audience
will see that the apology is inadequate,
that they will get and try to figure out
people's motivations for the apology.
Oh, you're trying to protect
this but this is what you think
and if you really were sorry,
this is what you would say
and it's just like ,it
is just a part of culture
to have somebody do
something and then apologize
and then be jumped on for
apologizing not in the right way.
It makes it really difficult
to even want to apologize.
Now, there is a legitimate
assessment of an apology.
Yeah.
It's like we're not
saying that you shouldn't
assess someone's apology to
see if it's a real apology
and that if it's apologizing
for the actual infraction.
Right.
You know, so.
And we haven't had to do that personally.
I guess I'm just saying that when I,
because we are public
figures who invariably
or inevitably will offend,
already have and will continue
to, accidentally or whatever,
offend people and then at some point,
that offense may reach a threshold
where we feel like we have to apologize.
When I see it happening
because I can relate to just,
oh, the anguish that someone is,
ah, I shouldn't have said that
or I should have done that
and now, I got to figure out
how to craft this in a way
that will make it seem,
it's just I have sympathy
for people in that position
but I'm not saying that people
should be able to do what they
want to and then apologize.
I'm just saying that the
dynamic of apologizing sincerely
and being accused of it being insincere
is just something that,
it's just a troublesome
part of this the way
our culture works right now.
In my house, I hope that
we set up an expectation
of having to apologize
and then a practice of
forgiving each other.
I think that is a good practice
because demanding that
you never do anything
worth apologizing for or then
apologies become admitting
not just what you did wrong,
but like that you're a bad person.
We all do things that
we need to apologize for
so it shouldn't be a double
failure when you apologize.
It should actually be a victory.
A true apology should be a
victory, not a second defeat.
Yeah.
So, what are my takeaways
from this experience?
I'm gonna really think twice
before I use real names.
I've always gotten a kick
out of using real names.
Matter of fact, in that
same first memories episode,
and I will use the real name
because we got his permission
for the Tour of Mythicality.
My first best friend Brad
McDonald actually emailed me
and he was the one who
did the orange hockey.
Yep.
Bright orange.
He was laughing and he was like,
my first memory is you
making me put my finger
in the light socket
and shocking myself.
I'm glad you finished
that sentence.
But I was like, man, people are listening
and thanks to Facebook, if nothing else,
things get around.
If people are mentioned,
it's gonna get to them
and I need to appreciate
that a little bit more
and so, I'm gonna try to
be a lot more sensitive
using real names because again,
I'm sharing my perspective,
it's like shooting from
the hip a lot of times
but that's one thing that I
just I got to get better about.
I think the second thing
is what we already talked
about about apologies.
And then,
this is not what made it all worth it
but boy, it's a sweet, sweet silver lining
to this story that quare came into it.
The thing I didn't tell you
was before I read her response,
which she used the term quare,
again, it was in a
forwarded email from Greg
and Stevie was on the thread
and so the first thing that I read,
like it pulled up on my phone,
you can see the first
few lines of an email
and it was from Stevie and it said,
"Ladies and gentlemen,
"I think we have seen
our very first occurrence
"of quare in the wild."
And you have never seen me clamor
to put the face ID and open up an email
as when I read that from Stevie.
I'm like, "What?
"What did she say?"
Now, it wasn't just as
she accept my apology
but how did she used quare?
Does she use it right?
Did she spell it right?
Again, it's a sweet, sweet
silver, it's so validating, man.
So eat it, Rhett!
I don't think I've got to eat anything
because I still think that
the origin of the word
is a bastardization of the word queer.
I just think--
Okay, I agree with that.
Most likely.
That the circle of people who do that
is a little bit bigger than your family
and includes your babysitter's family.
So I'm glad you feel
vindicated and you know what--
You know what, she was quare.
Yeah.
My babysitter was quare.
I mean how else do you get,
do you dare someone to pull up,
yank a ward off your finger?
That's a quare thing to do.
That's a quare thing to
do and I love her for it.
I got a kick out of it.
People were appalled but
like I shared it for the,
because it was wild, man.
When I told Christy this whole story
and I sat her down, her and Lando down,
we were sitting outside
drinking some coffee
And whatever--
The way that you're talking today
is like you're purposely saying
things that are people take,
sitting outside drinking some coffee.
I asked him to stick his
finger in the light socket.
Are you doing that on purpose?
No, I'm just talking, man.
Be careful, man.
You're the throwing curve balls.
I gave her and Lando this podcast,
like I made him sit
through the whole thing
and I read all of it and at the very end,
when I guess allowed them
to get a word in edgewise,
the first thing Christy said was,
"I now have the perfect word for you.
"You are quare."
Yeah.
And I was like, "Nanny and Vicki called me
"that my whole young life."
Yeah, it's perfect.
And I wear it as a badge of honor.
You're quare.
Just yourself be if quare is you.
But given the fact that it's sorta close--
Don't do it.
To queer.
Whatever you're trying to do right now--
No, no, no, no.
Do not do it.
I'm just saying that--
Don't take this from me.
I think that it could,
people could, again, you
might end up doing something
that then you have to then apologize for.
Like, if you wanted to
have t-shirt that says,
I'm here and I'm quare!
Like you can't take
that, you can't take that
because that is already a thing
that people who are actually
identify as queer say
and they use it in the modern--
I didn't use that.
The modern vernacular.
I didn't say--
But you just said, "I'm quare."
And I'm just saying the next thing
that might come out of your
mouth is I'm here and I'm quare
and I'm just saying that maybe
that is not the path for you.
Yeah, I don't wanna infringe.
Like don't get a tattoo
that says quare for yourself, you know.
No, that's okay.
That's not infringing.
Are you saying you...
Okay, I think what I'm
saying is I think that quare
is an appropriation and so
now, you're gonna be guilty
of appropriation--
Old English queer.
And that then you got
to apologize for that
on the Internet and then
people are gonna say
that your apology is insincere.
I'm just looking out
for you as your buddy.
As your your slightly less quare buddy.
You seem pretty quare right now.
You're being real quare.
We've dug a little hole at this point.
A little bit of it.
Again, I wanna thank
your name's not Betty one more time
for being so gracious in your response
and I just got the,
and I told her this in my response.
I just got the biggest kick
out of the whole thing.
And then she went on to say that she,
when she originally got worked up,
she had watched the Facebook clip
but then she went back after my response
and she listened to the whole episode
and within the context
of the whole episode,
it actually cleared some of it up
but I told her I wanted
to talk about quare
and she said, "I have a very
pronounced Southern accent
"and I've always heard the use of quare
"although I am pretty sure it was,
"in some cases, misused for queer.
"And I am still guilty of
saying don't be so quare LOL
"or more like ain't no need
"of being so damn quare about it."
That's what she says.
Like being very
persnickety about something
that doesn't matter
because you're just weird.
Mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
That's me.
Yes, it is.
Yeah.
Anyway, you can use our conversations.
Hopefully, it will allow a dialogue
and a better understanding for others.
If you need me to sign
something, let me know, thanks.
Sorry about the emoji.
I can't figure out how to remove it.
It was though as a winky face with the--
With the tongue out.
Hold on, which is that's what you do.
We are kindred spirits,
me and named not Betty.
Hold on,
that's the emoji that you do all the time.
No need to remove that.
Next time I go home, I got a hang out
with her name's not Betty.
We gotta quare it up.
Have a quare convention.
Well, if it's me and her name's not Betty,
if I can get two other
people who are quare--
Quare square.
Foursquare.
You think you can find four
people who use the term quare?
You know what, if you are from
the South or from anywhere--
No, from anywhere.
If you're a person.
And you used the term quare in the sense
that we have described it today.
#EarBiscuits.
Let us know, please.
Please.
Please, I would love
every week on this podcast
to read one more person who validates
my use of the word quare and
also validates me being quare.
Because I would I would definitely,
I would think that you, the
further the radius extends
from that part of Harnett County out,
the more validated you should feel.
So if there's somebody--
I don't know if I can feel more validated.
So somebody like moved to Alaska
and took quare with them--
Oh yeah, if it's getting out there--
That's a big radius.
I think we're doing it now.
I don't know if we should though.
People talking about quare and hockey.
I just think, again, for
reasons I just talked about,
I think it could be
misunderstood so easily
that I don't necessarily
think we should be proponents
of you the usage of the word quare.
The power of words.
Exactly.
Rec, baby rec, baby rec.
Is it my rec time or is it Rhett's?
It's yours.
I would just like to recommend
that you climb a tree,
especially if you're
not a tree climbing age.
I recommend that you climb a tree.
You don't drop what you're doing to do it
but next time you see a tree,
a climbable tree, do it.
Interesting.
Little quare of you.
Thanks for letting me tell that story.
You need me to go help you
clean up the rest of your trash?
Nope, hosed it down already.
Okay.
Good to go.
I will speak at you next week.
Stay quare.
To watch more "Ear Biscuits",
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of "Ear Biscuits",
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.